hi guys I'm Greg Tony Gil
Tony Gil Theresa on instagram it's in
the gamer on twitch same sitting a game
and justice Sara shatter alliances what
part 5
now we've seen like 50 other injustice
trailers the games right around the
corner what harm will one more trailer
do this is actually going to tell us all
of the store all the stories human in
two minutes that's an exciting stuff
this is what we're paying 60 bucks for
the alcohol reference
yeah no it's the density reversibly cup
come on begin the counter
well the end of the rainy my break
interesting comment robot my six one you
call Superman you have no idea what
Brainiac entails views I believe like a
destroyed Krypton
they're afraid of it how do I beat him
we can't
Superman supply for example four cycles
I must go back
oh yeah oh yeah Brainiac and I just got
the rivers
[Music]
you cannot match my actually allow me to
give you a proper demonstration
[Music]
the plan is to work in progress first
climb is so much
and okay that looks like it's the main
plot of the game we've been getting like
I read another story oh yeah
like you feel like at one point for one
of the Justice videos that it was like a
Batman vs. Superman thing of course
yeah after throws it in there but at one
point it looked like it was a Superman
breaking out and he's gonna bring us a
Wyatt and now it's about them fighting
but now it looks like it's all I'm
centered around Brainiac come and
destroy take out cow those graphics are
so dope man it's like I always get more
interested in just watching the video I
was really want to play and that was
cool same Brainiac in there it really
was cool seeing Brainiac and he is one
of Superman's ultimate daddy's having it
like that man thinking he can play on
without super Ram double yeah and we
just say that this is the first video I
feel like I've seen where it looked like
Batman was actually getting beat up yeah
every other videos like Batman could
like be fighting the flash and still to
club him up or like Superman it's true
well this trailer is good because it
really does set up Brainiac as a
terrifying villain because everyone's
getting their ass handed to them in this
you know all abrini X little robot
minions are [ __ ] up everyone to
finally puts like what this story is
about and just play ads like this whole
time we're getting all these bits and
pieces but this one is like okay got it
I'm [ __ ] into it I'm ready for the
game next month I don't know how they're
gonna throw us another trailer for them
but if they do I'm hoping this is the
last trailer
I hope they stock here and don't
continue any more hit games right around
the river he'll need to put in the air
they already have like gameplay
outputting stuff so it looks like yeah
if you want to think anybody can see
that you know these stories you can do
it which is wait until the game concept
my favorite thing about injustice is
more than the fighting mode is the story
I love the story so if this is the story
they're going with I'm on board to play
that he's gonna be live-streaming that
I'm probably gonna be there right there
with him on Twitch understand yeah just
think May 15 I'll be there I'm gonna
actually play the story and says
you'd answer yeah yeah we're gonna we're
going to do this keep a lookout for that
they'll be an announcement hey subscribe
to the real rejects it's in the gamer on
twitch treaty on Instagram we recently
launched the patreon Joe join the
community over there I got a lot of
lovely friends that have been helping
support the community they're [ __ ]
awesome as are all you guys so go over
there check out our patreon as soon as
you can and thank you for watching this
video which the ad revenue during on the
ad pocalypse would guarantee a solid 25
cents mmm good 25 cent get 25 cents man
nothing down on a water down the street
hopefully business